with both a record low percentage of
young americans eligible to serve and an
even tinier fraction willing to consider
it joining me now is stu sheller a
marine corps lieutenant colonel
discharged after criticizing the
military's afghanistan withdrawal he's
also the author of crisis of command
stewart um this really is the chickens
coming home to roost uh moment i think
you predicted it i predicted it they
want the military military to be like
you know i don't know harvard you know
harvard law school like a thursday night
seminar where
it's not it's no really different from
any college campus
yes laura thanks for having me on
bottom line you alluded to it this is
not a recruitment problem this is a
problem with our senior leaders our
senior leaders inability to have a
courage their hypocrisy it's affecting
all other things you would think a young
american would want to raise their right
hand support and defend the constitution
similar to your last guest talking about
wanting to support and defend the
constitution and have trust in our
senior military leaders but our senior
military leaders have demonstrated
through action that we can't trust them
and you would be naive to think that a
young american isn't getting online
going on the internet and seeing all the
missteps that we can clearly see of our
senior military leaders i was lucky
enough to be at the um michael murphy
navy seal
museum opening at long island today
and had a chance to meet so many
incredible men and women and in uniform
and former seals and so forth and
looking at the wall of all these special
operators who gave their lives uh for
this country and i actually got angry i
got angry about what's happening to this
military and all their sacrifice and the
families who are still sacrificing to
this day
we owe them
a lot
and a lot better than this
yeah i actually just spent some time
down in texas with morgan and marcus
latrell i saw some pictures at the at
the museum
and i was talking to marcus and he was
talking about our generation born in the
70s and 80s that has been forged in fire
through combat where our senior leaders
have made consistent mistakes but i
think it's our time to step up and get
us back on track to a constitutional
mindset we need leadership we need
courage i think that's what the 22
election cycle is going to be about
that's what i'm dedicated to and i think
our senior leaders need to wake up to
the real problems right now yeah we're
going to need a new commander-in-chief
for that i think here's something else
affecting recruitment
and retention since the military's
coveted 19 vacs mandate over 5 000
military members
were discharged for refusing to comply
stuart most these people are in good
health a lot of them have already had
covid how do we expect the military to
meet their quotas when we're kicking out
perfectly healthy men and women
yeah laura i'll tell you firsthand that
those numbers are much larger especially
if you start going in the national guard
or the reserves you start getting into
the 40 to 100 000 there's still a bunch
of medical waivers that are making it
hard for them to discharge but the
problem is much bigger than the 5000
that you described and it even is
exacerbated by people coming in right
now we have a senator candidate in new
hampshire don boldick a former one-star
general his kids were through art went
through rotc and we're told right at the
end that they couldn't join because they
weren't going to get vaccinated and then
they were told that they had to pay back
the rotc scholarship
all of these service members that have
served for two decades in war they made
an individual medical choice not to get
vaccinated i don't care what your
opinion is but for you to say that they
don't deserve an honorable discharge on
the way out the door is criminal and
it's indicative of our lack of courage
and hypocrisy in our senior military
leadership yeah again the
the message comes from the top and
republicans are the ones who help fund
all of this so the republicans have to
at some point um lieutenant colonel
sheller they have to say no more not a
dime is going to go to this diversity
equity inclusion nonsense and then
follow through on it and they just have
to um we appreciate you we appreciate
you and your book hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else